America just when you thought you had
seen every Scandal out of Washington
there's this a staffer for Democratic
senator Ben Carden is out of a job and
it comes after a graphic sex tape was
filmed in a historic Senate hearing room
Capitol Police are investigating how it
was allowed to happen the Senate sex
tape was recorded last week but the time
of day is unclear it's the same esteemed
place where Supreme Court Justices had
their confirmation hearings where the
911 Commission uncovered what happened
there and it's where James Comey
testified against former president Trump
the identities of the people involved in
the video have not been confirmed but
legal experts think they could face
criminal charges like trespassing
meanwhile some in the media are really
spinning this story NBC News blames
conservative outlets for reporting that
a Democratic Senate staffer filmed the
sex video in a Capital Hill hearing room
Greg this is a early present thank you
so much Monday a sex tape before
Christmas I mean I promise not to open
it but it does look like uh Joe Biden's
motorcade wasn't the only thing rear
ended
oh that joke would work if you could see
the pictures and I have seen the
pictures and I have to tell you it
definitely is a sex tape uh but the uh
so-called accused which we cannot
mention claims that this accusation is
based on homophobia and that's
predicated on the idea that people are
outraged over the ACT which they aren't
they're reacting to the where mhm you
know they always pull this this trick
you know they're banning books no
they're moving them it's not the book
it's the location it's not transphobia
to say reject uh gender activism in
middle school or reject Men playing in
women's sports it's not the what it's
the where that's how it always is so
it's like the Dam's favorite hobby is
not simply an acceptance of Behavior the
be as as a conservative and a
Libertarian I don't care what you do you
can do whatever you want in the privacy
of wherever but they always go to
towards eliminating the barriers to
location so you know I have nothing
against sex drag queens sexually
explicit books I don't care but I'm
smart enough to respect you know
appropriate ages and locations I like to
see men in sports but not beating up
women in sports right I don't want a
klepto in charge of our nuclear you know
our nuclear waste so it's not the what
it's the where and I reject the premise
that even talking or joking about this
is homophobic it's hysterical there are
so many puns that I'm refraining from
because I'm saving them for tonight's
show I we we're going to have to watch
that because there might be something
people really want to see there might be
some literal breaking news there might
be some breaking news all right the
other thing is that the NBC news like it
was basically saying conservatives pound
pounce because they didn't want to
actually cover the substance they just
wanted to consider the source well I
don't like pouncing but it's my job Dana
and I made a few gay porn movie titles
about this Senate Scandal would you like
to hear them don't know the seat of
government oh nice reclaiming my
behind like reclaiming my time not bad
uh
testimony okay that's a good one
rogering the witness H what's that mean
stop it Dana badgering the swearing in
and out and Ben cardon's cheeks of
Staff now I came up with those in five
minutes because I'm a sick
puppy but when I realized that this was
a Democrat staffer I have to say I was
very
relieved but I should have seen it
coming I know after they did the fire
alarm pulling the throwing of the elbows
a sex tape was inevitable
and now it's aace to the bottom Greg
they have been telling us the Democrats
that they need to keep the government
out of the bedroom well they just turned
the government into the bedroom Jessica
I like it and to me this is worse than
January 6th so much worse because they
say they defiled the Congress on what is
this we had a couple guys throw their
feet up on nany's desk what is this they
said they obstructed an official
government proceeding
They delayed the certification for like
what two hours they're not going to be
able to have a hearing in this room for
weeks this thing needs to be deep
cleaned now
also I was told that there was the
German guy who was on top now if I was
Joe Biden I would summon the Ambassador
immediately because you know from trade
from not paying their NATO membership
dues they have been taking advantage of
Americans for far too long theyve been
screwing everybody screwing the American
people it's time for the German free
ride to end Greg yes and I just hope the
guy's not
pregnant you said men could get pregnant
and if they are pregnant I hope they
have the baby yes permission to be taken
seriously
no well knock yourself out let's see how
that goes you can't do this and get
caught and claim you're the victim
that's the hunter Biden defense you
can't break all the laws or all of our
moral codes and say no for judging me
that's wrong you can't judge me that's
what Hunter has done that's what when
you break the law you say oh it's
systemic racism or I'm the victim of
capitalism if I'm homeless we have to
bring shame back Jessica well that's the
thing I don't think he has any shame
right he was like well one if you're
filming yourself doing that I mean
obviously there's no there's the problem
also that Ben carden's office knew that
he apparently had some known problems of
this sort in the past not in the capital
but of posting in appropriate social
media messages yes I've seen a lot of
them now I extensively prepared for this
segment as I do for all my segments I
appreciate that you did today though
that was really big of you this is the
Vindication of Madison
cauthorne remember when he said
everyone's always asking me to do it at
work and they have all these big orgies
going and I appreciate that he tweeted I
hadn't thought about him in a long time
and he said I Told You So or something
like that over the weekend
um
everyone January 6 is worse everyone
knows that why Amy kashar why her seat I
think that's really strange that that
was his selection for it highlighting oh
it was a great view like if you were if
you watch the video which I did um it
does make it on the serious note really
hard for people who are actual victims
of homophobia or discrimination in any
way whatsoever he had had problems with
this before with a social media post I
know he's trying to reference back as
well he had made some comments about you
know free Palestine Etc the obviously
gay community in Palestine is not
thriving they certainly wouldn't get to
do it at work like that and only lose
your job for it um but it does make a
mockery of people who have real
discrimination going against them and he
should be investigated to the fullest
extent whatever the law is about that I
I doubt they have something on the book
they'll we'll have to create with there
ought to be a law maybe um the other
thing is remember just a few months ago
there was this uproar about the
relaxation of a dress code on the Senate
side so people still want the place to
be revered as a place of dignity where
we do the people's business well I
usually try to do a lot of research to
come to the show but I did not do a deep
dive into this topic because I didn't
want to have to un not be able to unsee
things on the internet saw and the
search history as well really glad I
went to journalism
school to dig into this situation but
for me for the revered part of the
Senate right whether you know it's
becoming a joke based on the dress code
being that taken away whether it's the
American people not having trust in the
Senate having their best interest in
mind I know a lot of Senate staffers who
are not going home for Christmas because
they're working very hard to get a deal
done when it comes to this immigration
problem we're seeing at the border where
there are thousands of people coming in
every single day they're working late
night they're not fooling around in the
Senate room with whoever this may be and
for them they're very frustrated and for
people who saw what he said about this
being the criticism being about him
being a gay man they're in incensed
because it's like no it's about you
doing this at our place of work not just
where you work and there should be
consequences for it and there are and uh
I think that it was smart for the
senator just to get rid of him right
away instead of trying to play it out
and have some excuse about why
got it over with and also that Senator
is retiring at the end of this year he's
probably like what happened to the young
people on Capital Hill hi everyone I'm
Brian killme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now